8ax is an isometric Souls like game from
enemy entertainment and just because
it's in 2d doesn't mean it lacks depth
just take a look at this clip of me
fighting the first boss watch me trying
to balance my health my stamina my
healing flasks see me switching and
buffing my weapons here I'm trying to
fight off the hordes of enemies he's
summoning barely staying alive and just
looking for that gap in my enemy's
defenses I fought this boss over and
over for about an hour until I was
successful and I loved every second of
it but let's start at the beginning you
spawn in and instantly things feel
familiar you've got your attack your
kick your block your parry you can run
into a running attack your Dodge has
invincibility frames and your Estes is
in the bottom left to help you along the
way are even these messages on the
grounds that teach you the controls and
introduce you to new concepts as you go
to a souls fan it's nothing new and I
think that's ok who doesn't want more
souls after all the game translates the
souls formula really well to this 2d
isometric viewpoint as you watch all of
these fights and as you watch this
footage take a moment and just notice
how good the combat is I approach every
fight differently depending on the enemy
that I'm facing if they're these tall
shielded skeletons I defend against
their initial attack then I kick away
their guard and I lay into them if
they're big and hulking I tend to dodge
around their attacks if I'm facing these
aggressive assassin enemies then I kill
them before they can kill me because
they have no real defense I carefully
manage my range my stamina and all of
the resources I have available this
should sound really familiar right the
combat is tight it's varied and
responsive but it also requires you to
think critically about the best way to
deal with certain enemies just like
Souls one of the first major things
that's different is the loot system the
devs have mentioned that the loot system
works
more akin to Diablo in that enemies drop
randomized loot with different rarities
and stat benefits and in my first
playthrough right I simply could not
beat the boss so I went back through the
level once and I killed all the enemies
and I picked up another round of loot I
got a bunch of new armor pieces and some
rings and I managed to beat the boss
after I did that and that felt good
these enemies that I killed they still
had value even after I'd moved on from
them and by contrast in a Souls game
there's never really a reason to go back
and kill enemies that you've already
progressed past in ATAR randomized loot
makes even boring enemies exciting
because you never know when they're
going to drop something neat and you
know even though the enemies are really
easy to run past it's not a good idea to
do that because your character is going
to be underpowered
as a result what's more because the game
actually motivated me to go back and
kill some enemies
I found a side path that I missed before
down this side path there were a bunch
of new enemies and I ended up finding a
great sword awesome the great sword
requires two hands and it's slow but it
makes up for it because it crushes the
enemy guards and it has this fantastic
charge attack where you dash forward and
do an uppercut and that's another thing
I need to mention every weapon you find
in this demo is really important the
great sword for example it's unmatched
when you need to take out a group of
enemies fast the bow is excellent when
you want to lure enemies one by one and
fight them carefully or if you want to
pick them off at a distance the sword
and shield are fantastic for one-on-one
fights especially when you're doing
fights that you're unfamiliar with
triangle with some weapons allows you to
use a sort of weapon art for example the
shield has a frost parry
if you find the axe you can dual wield a
short sword and axe for more dps and
less defense triangle with this weapon
combination buffs your weapons for a
short time like using pine resin in a
souls game and the cool thing about
weapon arts like frost shield and
electric dual wield is that they
recharge when you play a certain way for
example you get more charges of frost
shield when you block attacks and you
get more charges of electric weapons
when you damage things so when you have
those weapons equipped it rewards you
for playing to your weapons strengths
these are just all these really cool
design choices that they've made that
really make you admire their attention
to detail so I found myself using every
weapon combination to deal with
different situations making my character
feel like she could adapt to anything if
I just gave it some thought and there
were a lot of situations where you had
to think here for example the best way
to take out these warriors was luring
them to the traps this group of enemies
rushes at you after you clear a wave of
arrows and there's no retreat here so I
died a couple of times because I
couldn't reposition myself the great so
what I found was one of the best weapons
to use here because you weren't forced
backwards when you were using it you
just sort of slaughtered the enemies in
your path and you took a bit of damage
but they didn't force you back into the
arrows so that was good
this next combination of enemies was
really tough because the big brute like
enemy he hid behind the smaller shield
enemies and it was difficult to get in
close because the threat of the big
enemy was always looming over you while
you tactically tried to get rid of the
little guy as shields and yeah this was
tough this next combination of enemies
was arranged wizard and three assassin
class skeletons best way to take them
out just overpower the skeletons before
they can hit you and when you make it
past all that assuming this trap doesn't
kill you if you're listening closely you
start to hear the sound of guitar
a crackling fire I actually love that
the bonfire in this game has a really
really audible sound cue it means that
you're less likely to miss the bonfire
in souls games do you ever remember like
being on your last Estus flask and
praying for a bonfire and then it might
be in a room but you don't know it's in
that room so you go into a random room
you die and then you realize that the
bonfire was right next to you that whole
time in a tur well you can hear the
bonfire before you see it so you know
which direction you should go and that's
a cool little touch next to another
bonfire is the only NPC in this demo who
gives us a fancy blue sword and a bit of
exposition about the world and its story
ater
the namesake of the game is a poison
that corrupts everything it touches the
devs say that eita is what poisoned ye
gracel which is the World Tree and
source of all life by extension since
you gotta sell is corrupted so to his
man and we play as the shieldmaiden
somehow unaffected by this blight that
effects man and we're on a quest to save
the world tree from corruption because
if the world tree dies then everything
dies but I feel like if you thought the
story was that simple that you'd be
wrong from what I've seen every item has
a description in the inventory screen
that flashes out the game's story a
little bit more just like souls moving
on after hearing some basic story our
character receives a point of favor
which appears in the top left it comes
with the message the gods do not favor
those who fall which implies truthfully
that you lose this favor if you die now
the favor system is really cool because
while you have a point of favor in your
top left your character appears to do
more damage
and take less damage however if you
don't want to run the risk of losing
this favor and this buff then you can
invest this in stat points instead which
remain after death
so it's this call toss-up between short
term power or long term potential I can
just see it now like someone is going to
get every favor point in the game
they're never going to die and they're
going to just become this super strong
powerhouse who can't dial they lose
everything I can just see that happening
speaking of dying though let's talk
bosses which arguably was the best part
of the demo for me the again Walker let
me tell you they're not pulling any of
their punches with this guy frankly I'm
kind of amazed that a boss this hard is
in the PSX demo of the game one of the
devs mentioned I was one of the first
people to beat him and that's probably
because I sat down with the game for
over two hours you know to give you guys
an idea of how long it took me I played
for about two hours and the boss
definitely took me more than one hour so
at least 50% of my time was spent
fighting this boss the boss fight starts
off pretty slow it just lets you get
familiar with his melee attacks he has a
short stab and the slash and while I
didn't try to parry him I've heard
that's a really good technique at 90%
health he powers up and he develops a
bunch of magic attacks he has this
triple magic circle that you should
start running early for if you notice
him casting it or you can dodge through
it if you notice it too late he has a
huge powerup AoE attack that does almost
all of your health if you get caught in
it but it lets you hit him a lot of
times afterwards and lastly he develops
this bloody skull attack that is his
most annoying move it's tough to dodge
it does a lot of damage and in Phase
three it gets even worse phase three
starts at 50% health he summons for
apparitions to fight you and they're a
little bit weaker than the other
it's not they're damaged that's the
problem though these enemies will now
attempt to stun lock you while you fight
the boss because remember that skull
attack I mentioned well now the skull
summons these apparitions as well so
let's just take stock of what's going on
here you have this boss with a huge
health pool a variety of ranged and
close-range attacks and at 50% health he
summons enemies every single time he
does the skull attack this guy is no
joke my one gripe with it actually is
how tough it can get when he repeatedly
spams the skull attack because if you're
lucky he'll never use the skull attack
and if you're unlucky he'll just use it
over and over again so here's what I did
for this boss I would equip the great
sword and I would use it to take out the
groups of enemies as soon as I could and
then I would pull out my dual wielding
axe and sword and I would just go ham at
him and try to burst him down when there
were no enemies around and eventually it
worked if you guys want to watch me play
through the whole demo I actually
recorded a live playthrough a let's play
initially I was only going to make this
available to patrons but this game isn't
out yet there's not much footage online
and you all deserve to see how cool it
is so if you want to watch me struggle
with the game and struggle to do a let's
play because I'm not really used to it
then click the link in the description
and maybe you'll even think about
becoming a patron because I'm excited to
announce that patrons in the $5 tier
should be getting a playthrough of games
that I'm playing maybe once a week for
supporting the channel which is cool so
I'm hyped for this game clearly don't
have much bad to say about it and I
don't want to be too critical on the
game yet because it's not out so we'll
wait for it to come out then we'll do a
review and we'll talk about how good or
bad it is and yeah so subscribe look
forward to that and bear in mind that
the devs have to flesh out so much to do
with the game they're probably still
developing the story they're going to
add in more weapons and armor sets a way
to level up a way to customize your
characters playstyle and all the little
tweaks to N
and animations and environments so yeah
sometime in 2016
Eric am I going to have a good time so
thanks for watching guys and I'll see
you in the next one Cheers
you